si vous nous suivez en direct il est
presque 18h30 dans une demi-heure une
manifestation à versaill des opposants
au texte du mariage pour tous au projet
de loi tobira ils doivent se réunir
place d'Armes avant de défiler dans les
rues nous avons en ligne Christine
jeunevoie bonsoir à vous bonsoir vous
allez participer à cette mobilisation
cette manif pour tous vous êtes une
citoyenne qui a décidé de s'engager
contre ce projet de loi pourquoi tout
simplement retourner dans la rue encore
aujourd'hui et bien parce que parce que
nous voulons nous faire entendre parce
qu'on a l'impression d'être maîtrisé et
pas entendu depuis tout le début de
cette affaire et parce que en fait c'est
une c'est c'est comment c'est un
mouvement irrépressible qui c'est c'est
nos convictions qui parle euh et qui
nous anime et on on on se dit que c'est
c'est trop grave pour lâcher l'affaire
euh parce que euh d'ailleurs une bonne
partie des Français commencent à s'en
rendre compte puisque le dernier sondage
BVA indique que 50 % des Français sont
contre le mariage et l'adoption par des
couples homosexuels parce que nous avons
bien pris conscience que c'est tout un
engrenage qui qui rentre avec cette loi
et qui qui va provoquer des situations
profondément injuste qui vont consister
à dire à des enfants qu'ils ont deux
pères ou de mères et donner finalement
un droit à l'enfant au couple homosexuel
et on sait parfaitement que le nombre
d'enfants disponibles à l'adoption éant
insuffisant et bien l'engrenage va nous
amener euh quasiment automatiquement sur
la PMA et la GPA vous é mobiliser déjà
he sur sur Versailles puisque là on
parle d'une mobilisation qui va
intervenir à Versailles dans dans les
prochaines minutes d'ici une demi-heure
si vous nous suivez en direct sur TVfil
en ce 16 avril vous étiez déjà présente
à versaill avec les manifestants
j'imagine vous étiez près de 20000
d'ailleurs en février dernier vous
imaginez qu'aujourd'hui il sera le
nombre de manifestants cette barre des
des 20000 personnes présentes à
Versailles sera sera dépassé
est-ce qu'il a été facile en tout cas de
de mobiliser parce que ça s'est fait
dans l'urgence cette fois-ci oui alors
ça s'est fait dans l'urgence et la
différence avec la dernière fois c'est
que cette fois-ci il y a également des
manifestations à l'Assemblée nationale
il y a beaucoup d'ivelinois qui
travaillent sur Paris et qui vont
rejoindre directement l'Assemblée
nationale sur Paris donc c'est pas sûr
qu'on est autant de monde sur versaill
mais ça veut absolument pas dire que la
mobilisation se relâche parce que je
peux vous dire que les gens sont très
mobilisés autour de enfin dans les gens
que que je côtoie qui se sont mobilisés
depuis longtemps et même des gens qui
qui se mobilisent maintenant puisque
finalement le comportement du
gouvernement euh ne fait finalement que
renforcer la mobilisation le
gouvernement qui a décidé d'accélérer un
peu le calendrier puisque finalement le
texte qui a été voté au Sénat en fin de
semaine dernière sera présenté à
l'Assemblée pour une adoption définitive
dès ce mercredi si jamais d'ailleurs le
texte était adopté très rapidement par
par l'Assemblée nationale en lecture
définitive vous cesseriez vos
mobilisations comment va s'organiser
ensuite comment vous imaginez la la
suite du du mouvement et en tout cas
votre action aussi également citoyenne
et bien en fait c'est c'est un petit peu
ce que ce qui nous désole c'est que le
gouvernement n'a jamais essayé de
comprendre de de nous de nous rencontrer
et de comprendre ce qui nous animait
vraiment et en fait et il pense que en
refermant le dossier rapidement il va
faire retomber la mobilisation mais je
pense que c'est absolument pas vrai ça
veut dire que la mobilisation va se
durcir on en a aussi entendu parlerin
très récemment encore ces derniers jours
durir se durcir je sais pas si on peut
dire se durcir mais en tout cas elle est
vraiment ancrée c'est c'est c'est une
question de conscience vous voyez c'est
c'est quel ch de viscéral qu'on défend
on défend vraiment la l'enfant le plus
faible le plus fragile qui n'a pas de
voix pour se défendre et on et on
s'ériiche contre cette injustice qui lui
est fait et surtout on s'éiche contre le
risque de marchandisation
marchandisation des gamèes du corps
humain marchandisation du corps de la
femme marchandisation de l'embryon
marchandis enfant tout petit si on
entend vos revendications je vous repose
tout de même cette question est-ce que
vous pensez que le mouvement va encore
ensuite perdurer même si le texte est
adopté est-ce que le mouvement peut
encore se durcir vous nous dites on
n'est pas sûr que le mouvement va ciè
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a eu quelques
dérapages même de la porte-parole de la
manif pour tous qui parlait d'appel au
sang même si elle est revenue sur ses
propos ouelle elle est revenue dessus
hein elle a dit que queelle regrettait
ce propos-là et qu'elleappelle
absolument pas au sang puisque on veut
c'est c'est un mouvement qui est
déterminé qui agit avec fermeté mais
pacifiquement parce qu'on pense pas que
la que la violence soit un bon moyen
d'expression voilà donc c'est ferme
pacifique mais déterminé et cette
détermination ne se relâche pas parce
que je vous dis que l'enjeu est vraiment
vcéralement important justement si cette
mobilisation est forte si comme vous
d'autres participent à cette
mobilisation avec cet engagement à côté
du côté de versaill pardon sur la place
d'Armes où doivent se rassembler les
manifestants merci Christine jeevie
d'avoir été en ligne avec nous vous êtes
l'une des opposantes à ce projet vous
serez donc à versaill d'ici une
demi-heure au côté des organisateurs de
la manif pour tous